dans un désert à pitoyable où règne la
terreur c'est tout moche et pas fini
mais c'est pas votre faute vous aime
bien quand même le courage de deux
petits et mignons et je ne suis pas
petit et on n'est pas mignon va jouer
leur destin à jamais je fais partir et
genre tu veux aller où
juste vivre dans l'oasis tu plaisant car
non seulement on peut pas y rentrer et
on peut penser c'est gênant non il
présente pas grand mystère loisy sa
partie en serpent vert mme c'est ici que
tous nos ennuis ont commencé
s'il se plaît me dit rires
il faut sortir d'ici ils vont tuer
sortir mes parents je m'appelle et 20
wattez ajar
ok âge as tu vois j'aimerais aller plus
loin découvrir ce qui se cache derrière
ces rochers
un monde sépare de la liberté
eva
on doit sauver ma part
un seul d'entre eux sur vire
on est son seul espoir tu la connais pas
les gars si on parle bien de ma soeur
laisser tomber et intelligente
sérieusement
c'est passé c'était plus fort que moi tu
es tellement courage
tous super entraînés au cou alors si je
m'énerve ça peut très vite dégénérer
ne riez pas croiser comme une caravane
caravane de trois hommes et un enfant en
direction de sotchi ville avec des
dromadaires dans l'un portait deux
paniers d'où pendent un joli serpent
vert qui cherchent à s'échapper
oui oui oui c'est ça la console dit rien
du tout
[Musique]